before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of our daily videos guys
today we are not doing the members only
chat but during our normal streams it is
going to be members only starting soon
so if you want to be a part of the chat
sign up for our memberships while you're
at it we have a new facebook page and a
new twitch page the link is into the in
the description for both so go follow
our new pages and guys while you're at
it like the video a like is free so if
you guys are ninja watching in here we
got beef okay like the video subscribe
to the channel so
today is a special day because my family
is here
[Laughter]
[Music]
so to start everyone go around um tell
them how you're related to me and tell
them your age
and tell them
oh tell them your favorite animal
starting with chats
my name is chazz uh
i was adopted
brother
i'm 22 and my favorite animal is a bear
uh
good question my name is dan i'm her dad
theoretically
um
i like all animals so i don't like pick
favorites just like kids you can't your
favorite you like the chickens a lot
fine we'll stick with the chickens
my name is jennifer and i am 52 years
old even though i thought that's kind of
a cringy question for the mom but that's
okay
oh yeah i forget usually it's like yeah
i don't really care oh no i'm 51 sorry i
lied
uh and my favorite animal would probably
be a porpoise i guess
why a porpoise
they're kind of stealth and they like
doing gymnastics and i really love doing
gymnastics and i like the ocean and i
don't know they seem friendly they're
fun they're good pick mom yeah thank you
go ahead amelia i'm amelia i'm 15. i'm
that thing's sister uh my favorite
animal
i like kathy barros
what is it kathy barrow you don't know
what a captain no not a club i don't
want to speak to you anymore you're so
cute okay well i'm adam uh i'm i guess
one of her siblings theoretically uh my
favorite animal is a wolf and i think
i'm 22.
pretty sure
did you forget i lose count every once
in a while
so i'm gabrielle i'm 20 i'm hannah's
sister and my favorite animal is a dog
what breed what kind of dog yeah an
australian shepherd
okay my name's eva i am 18. i'm hannah's
favorite sister
you're really rich with that one come on
i came to visit her you didn't
aren't we here visiting
okay but
mine was willing this was a forced trip
with mom and dad
you're not wrong
free trip what are you talking about
free
all right go ahead what's your favorite
animal
uh
a megalodon
um i don't know what that is but i'll
take your word that it's cool
okay guys well thank you for all coming
this is a very long trip just you know
guys this isn't all of my siblings
there's more but um this is all the ones
that could come on the trip so
today we are going to be taking
questions from the audience i know you
guys had so many questions about like
who my family are why are we insane you
know all that stuff so i'm going to
start with some of the questions that
were on the community post but if you
guys have a specific question that you
want to ask anybody on the channel or on
the panel then put it in the super chat
so
a lot of people are questions from mom
and dad
so i want to start mom and dad why'd you
decide to have so many children
because most people do too and stop so
like what what made you do that just for
the record it wasn't probably my choice
so i'll let her answer that question
i would say i always wanted a big family
i came from a big family dad's from a
big family so
actually to clarify her family were
small the only nine of them there was 13
of us so she
okay fine i had a mid family uh but i
really valued my siblings and wanted uh
a lot of kids um i wanted five boys that
didn't sort of work out i guess i got
five boys i just got five girls to go
with it
so that was it and uh when you guys were
little dad always said he would have as
many kids as i wanted to take care of
before they were three because he didn't
like babies and i kind of loved them and
that was perfect for me because i don't
really like sharing babies so
it was fine but he did he was good
so question um
you guys have been married 30 years now
30 everyone clap 30 years the average
the average first marriage um is eight
years in the united states
what do you what have you guys done that
you feel like is different than most
people
let's clarify one thing though we just
had 30 and i don't think we received any
present from you or anything just to
clarify this
okay sorry what's going on
do you give presents for anniversaries
you get like
i don't even know if anybody wished them
happy anniversary i did i did
good
okay so why do you feel like marriages
in 2022 like why why is marriage failing
and why what do you think you guys did
differently that you guys have been able
to stay married for so long
those are hard
i guess
to me when i think about it externally i
would say that people go into it
thinking there's an out
instead of thinking about it as
this is a decision for life
um you know that's one thing i think
that
um
yeah i don't know i think we've had a
lot of adventure and done a lot of
things
outside
for sure my comfort zone i think that's
straight in his comfort zone but
um yeah i don't know that's that's what
i would say i don't i don't think i
thought about it a whole lot i just
that's probably the best answer is you
don't think about it i mean
it's hard marriage is hard life is hard
and you just gotta take it as that and
say
either you work on it you don't and
that's the hardest part in life is
working it's like your job if you love
your job you work hard at it you love
your marriage just to work hard at it
and they all have ups and downs so
there's never an easy road
to either one to life or a marriage
and so
let's keep going dead so if you expect
it to be simple and easy then
it's gonna be it's not gonna last
so
and then the last big thing is which is
the hardest part to work on is a woman
has to understand the man's perfect
[Laughter]
did you have that understanding early on
mom oh she's still working on it
and so what do you see in like the new
generation that causes them to quit so
quickly
uh wow i think i mean honestly it's it's
seriously like attention span people you
know they get rid of their you know
their cars their jobs their spouses
their you know they just it's like life
attention span they don't think of
things long term i don't know that's
that's the thing i would say what'd you
say
no i'm sorry um
yeah
sorry good one dad
what do you think dad well that's the um
i think life is life is full of quick
moments i mean it's kind of like in this
vacation we want we
you look at the germans and they
actually went to the beach i'd stay
there all day
and for us americans it was like
okay we did that let's go on
and so i guess life's like that if you
don't
i guess you say s say saber the moment
so
and i don't feel we do
so in america oh god yeah not at all do
you think like we're they're always like
on to the next best thing okay yeah go
look at people on the beach go look at
i mean look at devices devices role real
life dude in america do you feel like um
you not being on social media and um has
helped
like do you feel like like that's helped
you guys stay married like not being big
into social media
i think that's kept me sane
i watch i watch go ahead uh i mean i
want to just inject that mom
from when she when we were young she
always took a lot of photos and always
was on facebook a lot but as the years
have gotten better she's gotten better
at it and doesn't doesn't spend so much
time doing it it definitely took away
from a lot of vacations and time spent
growing up and now it's a lot better
because
you actually get to enjoy vacations and
time with her because
it takes away a lot
it drop draws away your attention
completely you lose entire focus on
anything but the next like the next pose
the next thing
yeah and what what qualities do you want
us to look for in a partner
for the do the boys and the girls that's
a really good question han yeah
go ahead
yeah you know i think that like
i guess when i reflect back on
you know the decision to get married or
you know talk a little bit when dean and
i
met
there was a lot of characteristics in
him that i never thought about that
really would have been horrible had i
not had they not been there you know
just his work ethic so i would say that
um
you know all of you marrying people that
work hard because regardless you know
and maybe that goes back to the other
question why don't people stay married
it's because people don't know how to
work hard anymore and i think that's one
of the things i'm most proud of my kids
is they all know how to work hard and so
i think finding somebody who has a
similar work ethic to you
it has to be it's sort of like rowing a
boat if one person's rowing slow and the
other one's growing fast
it's not going to work right so you know
to me i think the work ethic is
something that's important and i think
also just a foundation in god and and
you know that being foundational in your
life i think is really critical
because you know
you either believe in god or you don't
and if you don't then you know it's just
a very different pursuit and of
happiness in life
yeah yeah i mean
the last part i would add that is
i mean not that and we did but i would
not recommend like working with your
spouse i think if separate times
together separate times together with
each other i mean so you can have a life
outside your normal life and i think in
our marriage that was a hard part of it
was working together do you feel like
um
do you feel like that's been like
helpful not working together anymore oh
god yes yeah
because you guys spent like 24 hours a
day all the time together for like what
20 years mom no i yeah i worked back in
the back room and yeah so
yeah we did very different things in the
business so we were in the business
together but not
interacting day-to-day i would say in
most things
and how so how did you guys start the
business
like when did that
how old were you well first most of it
was my brother needed a system
many moons ago back in the early 80s so
i guess a long time ago
and we started writing software then for
his business
on a mac
and 128 i think it was
back that's how long apple died yeah
and so then i i found the wrongs in my
ways i corrected them i went to ibm
i had rungs there corrected that but
whatever the bottom line is yes we
started in apple so yes i have a lot of
a lot of experience in the mac before
you guys all have these silly little
devices
it's a really interesting point coming
from a samsung man but okay
i learned the error in my way
okay
my dad my dad hates
um apple he's anti-apple
there's a divide there's something that
we fight about as a family and it's
apple versus samsung
it's male gets female because basically
all the males have
i have uh samsung okay no i have a
google phone actually oh yeah mom you're
the outlier
so another another crazy thing is so you
guys had you had six kids
and then you guys decided to adopt three
what are you guys insane
i think they just sort of landed on our
land
let's clarify that because um let's just
start with chas because it's easiest one
um the guy in the corner hey hey
hey
i brought chaz home one day
like a new puppy says i'm dominated the
wrong way but and the next thing you
know after about a week we go and ask
him
so uh chad's hanging out
or is he staying and what did you tell
us adam
oh uh i already gave him a bed he lives
here now
so so adam brought chaz i remember
because i went home from college and i
was like like you guys didn't say
anything chaz was just walking around
and i'm like
who's that
and he didn't really talk then either so
it's like
he's he's much better now oh no he talks
all the time now chazz is hilarious
so
you guys so let me get this straight
your son brings home another kid from
school and you just like okay well it
made sense yeah so i mean they gave us
good reasons i think at the time
i'm not sure what they were but they
probably were good
i think both of us are problem solvers
and empathetic people and so it just put
us in
situations that we wanted to help
and then to add to that
mary my niece actually
13 14 my sister called me up one day and
said hey i can't deal with this kid
anymore could you take her
yeah and we said i think we said yes
that was the pg version yeah
true but bottom line is we got her at 13
we kept her until 18 and
and she's done well in life i mean just
it was just meant to help i mean it's
not i guess it takes a lot but when
they're not when they're over three it's
easy when the under three you can keep
them
but they were all teenagers when we got
them yeah that's also
not when most people are out shopping
for kids yeah you think it's like the
least likely to actually get adopted
wouldn't you
like teenagers i would think oh for sure
yeah for sure yeah because they're
trouble even your own
what do you mean
i was a perfect child
yeah i never did anything wrong nothing
i'm perfect
so
um let's not go into that history
i think about the only one that can
currently say that is amelia and she's
still a teenager so she's got a little
bit of time i feel like we wish amelia
got into a little more trouble
i think
i think mom and dad would be like you
did something
no i did get into trouble i just blamed
it on eva oh what'd you do say it into
the mic
no well i mean i don't know what you're
talking about our polish polaris ranger
can say uh say uh
what i don't get it what's the story uh
i think amelia should tell it i don't
think so
what happened
yeah and what happened the funny part
was i wasn't even there for this so this
gets even better for me i think chaz or
dad can demonstrate because i wasn't do
i want to tell this story i don't know
what it is it's not that bad it wasn't
that bad what'd she do she just had a
bunch of friends over and
took a corner to sharp no no start first
she first left the property and broke
the first roll
which was leaving the property oh yes oh
is she four-wheeling oh yeah oh guys so
we have four-wheelers if you didn't know
so we have like they're like atvs
and utvs yeah and utvs so we live on 40
acres and we like a room room and you're
not you're supposed to stay on the
property and so she didn't uh of course
so she decided to leave the property and
go four-wheeling on the streets it was
in eva estates
former property yeah
[Laughter]
so oh so she so she kind of stayed on
the property she went to her road
formerly amelia doesn't have a right
oh yeah
we forgot about it
so technically she was on your road yeah
so we were we were super excited because
she was being social and having friends
over and uh the girls were all driving
like they
we called that they were like driving
like driving miss daisy they were all
driving super slow and cautious and then
suddenly she got a little speed
in her uh inner and uh yeah took a
corner too sharp and tipped the whole
thing over and did a bunch of damage and
broke some glasses and but nobody died
my glass is done i'm kind of proud of
her guys amelia likes to like stay in
her room so i'm like i'm like proud of
her for like you got out there good job
yeah yeah
amelia got in trouble
yeah amelia getting more trouble so
actually that's a question
you guys are really free-range parents
like you guys really weren't strict we
could pretty much like
i don't want to say do whatever we
wanted because there was always like
obviously limits but you guys what do
you think the benefits are to free range
parenting more because you know everyone
turned out okay you know we're okay i
think
rather than jazz
is chad's really the issue here adam
adam
so do you do you think that's better
than being like super strict with kids
i think it depends on the kid okay and
honestly some kids like so yeah it does
for sure
so i should i'll tell a hard story but
of course
so you can do it when adam was 14.
i can't do it yet yeah okay
i think that um when you think about um
parent like how i think about parenting
is that
kids today they can't make any decisions
so they get into
adulthood and they've never had any
practice and so it's like they're
overgrown children they're overgrown
children and so you know and and i know
when
like our first kids like i was
definitely far more of a helicopter
parent than with me
with the old the younger ones yeah i
mean just like bedtimes and what you ate
and how you dress oh i just i meant when
like i was in high school you guys no
but i'm saying like as when you were
young oh okay and as well i was kind of
overwhelmed by the time you were in high
school to be honest because there's a
lot of kids
oh yeah because i wasn't
it wasn't super strict when i was
growing up i don't think but the catch
was like this when adam was 14
he always said you never listen to me
first
so we from that point we did
i was always right first but no one ever
no one ever listened to me they just
kind of blew me off and every time i was
right i'd say [ __ ] you guys i told you
so and
well and so he became just the opposite
he was a pain in the ass so he finally
did that he changed to be a different
kid
and so that's the point is that you have
to deal with the kid
and based on that i mean like eva too
you just gotta deal with that it's a
personality yeah each kid is different
and different personalities and that's
like how do you deal with them you can't
there's no there's no set mold yeah at
least not die off so like some kids need
more structure than others exactly and
some and somebody less and some of these
things we listen to and some need to be
hugged
and just whatever
i like hugs
that's the point you can't just know
there's no set i mean some kids need to
be strict i mean just do
i mean chad's i think no king
how are you able cause one thing that i
always get a lot is
like we grew up in that like a one
percent family but we don't really act
like a like super stuck up and snotty
because because because even um growing
up like there's one comment that i felt
like really resembled our family in the
comments section it was like y'all are
rich but you look broke
[Laughter]
i wore my nicest shirt today i just want
to make this clear hey dad really likes
starbucks so how do you oh he likes oh
yeah he likes hot chocolate he buys
starbucks now he never used to and i
think like it's obviously different
based on the kid but like overall i
would say we're a pretty down to earth
family how did you keep us like that
even though we grew up with money so but
we didn't i mean lebron james a good
comment he told his son that
no son you're not rich i am no shaquille
shaquille shack jack did okay well i'm
sorry one of the famous basketball
players but the point was it's the same
we never really we didn't go on
expensive vacations we went on vacations
where we drove we
took off we did our own food we did
everything as if
i mean i guess it's because she's cheap
i i always spend money
i think yeah like a part of it too
hannah is that it goes back to the
comment about who you marry like work
ethic is really important we don't work
less today than we ever did we don't
treat money differently today than we
ever did you know do we have more money
sure but i don't value it less i don't
you know i work just as hard i don't
have any extra and so you sure yeah i'm
positive
no so i think just checking
but i think that you know that work
ethic like dan and i both grew up you
know our families didn't have much our
parents gave us nothing and uh that was
the best gift they've ever just for the
record i was going at 17.
oh you're gone at 17. i was young so
yeah
i was gone at 17 too yeah
so so just you guys know okay
and this expiration date's getting
higher well because that's the other
thing is it's i didn't realize how
all of my siblings like work hard
and that's like something you guys
really taught us was like even even like
i don't say even my laziest sibling is
harder working than like the average
person that i'm not gonna give names i'm
not gonna get but even my lazy laziest
sibling i would say is harder working
than like the average person i meet
and i think the other thing too is
first letter yeah
okay like everyone there's always a
first and a laugh like i'm not gonna
what one letter fits three so you know
so what i was going to say is that i
think everybody
everybody's kind like they all know how
to be kind and they know how to be
helpful so not only just hard-working
but helpful and i know you know i've
gotten messages from teachers i got one
from
amelia's teacher this year you know
about just going out of her way to help
another kid and eva i know there's
dozens of stories and actually there's
stories about you that i could tell that
were super sweet and just so beyond your
years and i think that you know that's
another just difference in how you guys
were raised you were you know i don't
want to say you're forced to be helpful
but the
the
combination of being from a giant family
and hard-working parents you had to be
helpful you didn't have a choice yeah it
was the only way we got attention
[Laughter]
probably not out of the line yeah
probably true
no because that's the one thing i always
i always credit like you guys to a lot
of like like obviously i would never
have built this show if i didn't have
you guys supporting me and i always say
like i would be nothing without my
family and like the people that like
supported me and i i'm just amazed um
you guys drive me nuts i'm not gonna lie
to you everyone
all of you but like at the end of the
day like i know i have really great
people at home and i know that like my
family is always gonna be there for me
no matter what and i just you know i
always really appreciated how hard you
guys worked because a lot of the times i
don't know if everyone really
appreciated how like especially you mom
with like our family trips going up i
would be so annoyed that i had to like
leave for half the summer
but like looking back like i'm so
grateful i have those memories like with
you guys and with my siblings and it
really taught me to be like
humble you know because like i was
always so jealous of my friends that
were like on
planes you know that would fly to their
vacations
because i'm like i have to go with this
band with all my siblings this is sona
but like like looking back like i think
it's really character building
how to deal with other siblings in a van
well you know i think everyone in our
family knows how to get along with
people because we had to we have 10
different personalities and sometimes we
want to kill each other but like
but we love each other at the end of the
day
yeah now i think there's i mean there's
a lot there that's there's a lot of
different things but
it's part of why we did vacation well
that and we just either didn't have the
money at the time or didn't want to
spend the money but
you know it's
it's
okay i was gonna say the best uh the
best story was you know maybe a decade
or so ago we were looking into upgrading
we have a the big red bus and the big
red bus has uh uh
35 000 miles on it so we've driven it a
lot and we were looking at upgrading it
and thinking about that that's what we
were gonna do and amelia said we can't
do that that's like our you know that's
our legacy that's our boss like we can't
get a new one and uh you know i think it
just it's a little bit of like it's the
story it's the history
and people just don't focus on that
let's not talk about the fact that it's
rusting out completely it's such a good
bus
if anyone if anyone wants to buy a 16
passenger yeah
i got a super chat from pa hecate um two
questions for um pearls oh pearls daddy
and mama pearl um
what has brought you the greatest reward
acquiring material things or family
experiences
well i think it's i think the trips by
far i mean the family trips work we have
some fun ones actually i wanted to ask
that question back
to each of you like what was the most
the trips all the trips we've been on
besides this one don't count this one
it's not over yet yeah it should be but
what's our favorite trip we've uh
um i really liked alaska
interesting and i also really liked we
had one trip to florida as a family
um
i just remember like i think gabrielle
was in like eighth grade so i don't know
how old i was you don't you don't
actually know what to say like that was
just a really fun trip because everyone
everyone just got along so well
and is that what the alligator one yeah
okay
alaska crocodile no
sorry i said um a florida trip and
alaska so alaska we didn't get along as
well um because it was three weeks in an
rv but it was still a lot of fun like we
did so much cool like the ice climbing
and the um hiking yeah and the hiking
and all the stuff we did was so fun
um
riding in an rv for three weeks
um yeah those are my two favorites what
about you go around chaz yeah chads go
[Music]
oh no
uh
i
don't know what counts as the trip for
yeah it's not super fair chance hasn't
been around that many years so there's
not that many trips and minutes our
hunting and snowmobile trips are the ski
trips he learned to ski oh i said i
guess i'll go with the snowmobiling
trips i really like the snowmobiling
trips those are always a good time or
the oh i guess actually i'd go with our
our utv trip to
we were in virginia west virginia west
virginia yeah that one was awesome
yeah was that the last one or the one
before that no that was the one before
that when we were in west virginia we
went up to wisconsin right last to you
right yeah
amelia what about you i liked the second
alaska trip we took mainly because it
was not as crowded
wait which the second alaska you weren't
there weren't there
oh that was rude
yeah we uh we went and i didn't even
hear about this channel well instead of
going downtown for the end of the year
we went to alaska because it was during
covet and the flights were really really
cheap only the favorite kids were
invited sorry hannah i was there
what about you adam it's definitely the
farm growing up um yeah grandpa's farm
was definitely the most fun that i had
ever had and that was
definitely one of the ones that i
enjoyed the most
gabriel i would say alaska because i
really like driving the cars i i got to
it was the second trip yeah the
demolition or the stock car you what did
it stack i got to go uh race uh cousin
brett ryan ryan sorry ryan has like the
cars up in alaska hand and
uh pearl sorry um they know my first
time
but
i got to race and then somebody hit my
back end i spun out but that was that
was fun i got to drive past i almost won
i was i was catching up man
only two laps behind hey
eva um i'd say it's close between the
second alaska trip and the utv that we
did the only thing that makes utving
kind of lose is i got food poisoning
so
i only went the first day which honestly
sounds like it was pretty bad the second
day for all of you so
everything broke down the second day
yeah it was like pouring rain oh i
wasn't there let's go back into that one
because dad's point from earlier when
listening to me first made sense
we were we were a lot stuck on the trail
and we turned off our quads to figure
out where we were and we turn off one of
the single seater atvs and it won't turn
back on and i go oh it's probably fused
check the fuse box and replace them they
go no no just keep going go home we'll
meet you guys at the house we'll tow it
back
they bring it back to the house and
about 10 minutes into opening it up and
fixing it they find it's a fuse gone
just want to say i clarified this four
times before i left and no one listened
to me and then well what do you know
just for the record he doesn't point out
the fact that it is
pouring down a range we had no idea what
the fuse box is brand new utv we had or
atv whatever it's a cross but atv so
we had we have an argument from our side
of just saying we just we just gave up
now of course towing it we broke another
atv
so that probably cost us even more but
the point was there's more external
factors that were not brought up
the point is i was right
adam's always right
so
another another question for you too
who is harder wait who are you more
worried about raising girls or boys and
in hindsight who is harder to raise wait
is that a question yeah yeah there's no
question okay what's the answer it's
very simple
girl's a lot harder to raise
why why
you hear that devilish crackling in the
background
adam let's not talk about what happened
in florida
florida i had a good time
adam adam lived in this part yeah adam
can i tell this story or no
adam lived in a multi-million dollar
mansion unsupervised for six months he
was over 21. yeah he was over 21 no he
wasn't he was not he was neither he had
a a
adam was 19. adam had a great time
according to everybody down there i was
over 21.
i went to his third 21st birthday party
so so even even with that escapade you
you still you still vote girls are
harder to raise
why
i think because there's more to so i
think first of all drama yeah
well i would say all of you were
relatively easy kids like babies i was
an easy kid dad why are you looking at
me baby i was like even me
no you were a really easy baby no i
meant toddler i thought i was a devil
[Music]
mm-hmm so i think overall overall i
think that you know you guys just
weren't that hard young
and then but with girls there's always
more to worry about there's more things
that can go wrong there's more i think
they're more easily influenced i think
you know boys it's like if there's
something wrong they just beat each
other up and it's over and girls there's
like drama for a decade do you do you
agree with the statement girls are born
with value while men have to create
value whoa
girls are so there's a man of sphere
saying it's called girls are born with
value where men have to create value
um
i can see that perspective i don't know
that i'd have to think about it longer
yeah but my but
everybody can work so everybody has
value i mean i don't get that
they're both valuable
just in different ways so i don't know
i've never thought that deep into that
but i would have a hard time
probably agreeing the statement so
i'm sorry keep going mom where you were
saying why it's harder
raising girls yeah i just think like you
know for example you know all of the
playdates happened at our house like i
mean it was very rare any of you went to
anybody else's houses because you know
what could
what could traumatize a girl
would ruin them for the rest of their
lives and like that was something that
was something i was super strict about
is like where where you guys were
sleeping you know who where whose houses
you were at
and those types of things and we always
just had everybody at our house because
then we could make sure so you know i
think that
from those perspectives i guess the
world
as a parent
it's
you have a bigger job to protect your
daughters from the world
is probably how i would say it
whereas boys you know i guess maybe if
you look back into you know the
evolution of humans boys were designed
to go out into the world
so i want to go around and everyone
starting with eva
i'd like you to say your favorite
memory growing up
it doesn't have to be a trip it could be
anything
really putting on the spot here here
yeah like there's a lot to go through
here how about we start with dad
[Laughter]
i think that'd be more anyway yeah does
anyone want to go first well my growing
up i mean honestly i think the most
favorite thing i had was i used to drive
motorcycle okay i wanted 185 orange they
painted black and my dad thought i was
crazy
but it was but it was dented so i
painted it to cover up the downspeed
that i was like going through this cult
thing
but i've read that thing everywhere i
mean i wrote that the fires on the farm
so i had
at that time 1200 acres to ride around
on so
it was great
until i got an accident and
that pretty much
[Laughter]
so
mom do you want to go um my growing up
or you guys growing up you could do
either
um
i think my growing up it was just the
simple memories of doing things on the
farm and with my brothers and we used to
like blow up cars and things and do it
like kind of dangerous things but really
fun
and i was much younger so i was one of
the younger ones so it was fun to see
what you know i guess my older siblings
would do
just for the record they did that just
before her wedding she wasn't always
young just to clarify yeah the last time
i got really yelled at by my dad was
like two days before our wedding
we sort of were blowing up cars in his
uh
in his um junkyard
yeah
so anyway that was what about you chaz
what's your favorite memory from since
joining with the fam since joining yeah
i think it's the time he lost me in
wrestling
which i remember that
yeah i don't think it exists i don't
think so
either ah
hmm
favorite memory
i don't know i can't think of right you
can't think of anything you liked no i
mean there's like tons i've liked what's
the first thing that comes to your head
right now um
working on that water slide we have in
case
yeah
dad could you tell the story about the
water slide
i was perfectly happy my plastic slides
the bottom line is it wasn't my fault we
got in that mess and i was happy camper
but somebody else had to go big
let's go big so of all of the really bad
ideas that we've had this one i have to
take a little bit of credit for
generally they start with dad
um but this one you know since i met him
he had always been building a water
slide and generally getting hurt on them
every year
one time one time every other time they
always worked out the farm slides were
good the castle sides were good except
for bad bad engineering
i think adam told me to put the thing
there and i did
i wish we could have like visuals like
the cast will slide yeah
so i googled used water slides and i
found a guy who's who uh
sold used commercial water slides and we
bought one and then we had to assemble
it but none of us have those skills so
it was like learning and i don't think
any of us realized how big it was and so
yeah it's like massive
there's just many things that weren't
considered in the price can you raise
your hand if you've been personally
victimized by this water slide
for the record we we changed it we
corrected them we corrected the errors
we learned from our mistakes actually i
saw the videos from fourth of july
i saw the videos they were on mom's tick
tock but that's the safe slide yeah
that's that's nice that's our improved i
know it still looks like
not safe wait wait it's just because
you guys drop off the edge
it's only eight to ten foot it's not
that bad hey hannah if it wasn't for
that slide you wouldn't be tick-tock
famous
that's true that did start my media
career
and just just the record though version
one
was was actually redone because actually
i got hurt
i thought you're a bunch of wussies and
whims until i felt the brunt of the side
of my head against the slide i got a
concussion from the slime i got a
concussion from the sun i fractured my
heel
well i think that was version two though
adam right now version two was a little
more dangerous actually probably the
most dangerous yeah so we did that one
only one time down
version three though i think is good
this version's actually no one's been
hurt in a while it's kind of boring
though i think i think this is also
version five i want to say i i don't
think we're at three that might be
underestimated a little bit basically we
bought the slide guys and we kept having
to re like fix it to improve it so
people didn't get hurt and the town
wanted to take it down didn't they
well they were against putting it up
because it kind of is
not the best thing neighbors i mean most
of the neighbors liked it this is one or
two they asked to use it what do you
mean
now
now
yeah the neighbors next door both
neighbor neighbors next door we asked
them before we bought it yeah so but
there was i mean a few things it was
bigger than we expected so it was you
know it goes from our front yard over
the house to the backyard so that's kind
of big um and when i got the permit from
the village you know we told them
exactly what we were doing but they when
they called me and said well we didn't
know you were building that kind of
slide
like you did an ask so that's not our
fault
it was approved by the board sorry guys
well they actually turned it down but
they approved it because they said it
was attached to the house it's then
basically a front porch and so we made a
front porch
we did exactly what they said
well they voted 7-0 against us for
stand alone but once we added that thing
to the porch they could do nothing so
big porch paw patrol innovative
yeah we're creative in this family
and now uh whenever you meet people in
the town and you tell them you know they
always ask you tell them where your
house is and they say where is it in
relation to the slide and then you say
we are the slide
and then it's one of two answers well
it's the same word every time but it's
one of two inflections it's either oh
or it's oh
and so you know exactly which side of
that issue they started yeah we had a
split we split the town
what about you guys favorite memory eva
you think of anything
um
honestly
not really growing up anymore recently
and it didn't involve any of the family
maybe amelia but we were driving home in
a storm from grandma's birthday
and my friend meredith we stopped in a
mcdonald's drive-through to go get some
food because we were hungry meredith
said i need to stand she got out of the
car stand outside she stood outside for
maybe a second or two before lightning
struck down on the ground maybe 200 feet
behind her
and then we started singing church music
the entire way home
wow
it was really scary
no it was really close
about you gabrielle um
so it actually has to do with casspill
as well uh it well back in the day
castle not the current casper with the
water slide um my favorite memory would
have to be the sport of tubing
um
i remember
some very very serious
tubing adventures and i can say that i'm
a pro now
uh any kind of you can do the
standalones you could do the top sitting
whatever i'm very good at tubing now so
i'd say the holding on for dear life and
being thrown 30 feet in the air that
that's that was fun
by who bloody oh um
raise your hand if you've been
personally victimized over the years by
dad throwing you off a tube
launching launching
i don't know the worst one i ever got
was austin was driving and he knocked
the wind out of me so badly that i
couldn't get out of the water for two
minutes and he dived in because he
thought i was gonna drown
that's what the life jackets are for
yeah
how about lake michigan when you kicked
your oh yeah okay i'm right he has had a
few
that's like the most scariest i need to
go back to lake michigan that was fun
not with the boat
i'm retired that's okay adam what's your
favorite memory
still would be the farm i mean i had the
most fun there growing up
amelia what about you building forts in
the basement oh yeah that was all about
that i remember us getting that like
tiny like i don't know what kind of tv
it was but it was really old and we'd
play super smash bros on the way on it
you know the big one the big old box tv
that had a
dvd
for the vhs a vhs player
and the base for gaming would always be
under the air hockey table yeah yeah and
you would set up too much when you like
won a game and you'd like bang your head
like we'll use the weights to do all the
blankets yeah i used to wonder oh so we
use those weights
[Laughter]
and then mom would yell at us and be
like i don't know why they're there adam
did it
yeah mom i didn't break that vase either
[Laughter]
can i ask you guys about greg or no
no i don't want to talk about no i'm
talking i'm talking to mom and dad
um
because um a lot of people had questions
because i always tell the story because
i'm pro-life
um so
i always tell the story like for me it's
a like
because you guys gave a kid up for
adoption it's really hard for me to like
be pro-choice because like i saw him
grow up and like become a person
how how did you guys come
to that decision like that's got to be
the hardest decision you've ever made
right
yeah i think um
first of all i'm proud that you're
pro-life because i think i just want to
say that because i think that in this
generation there's so much pressure to
not be so i just want to say that go you
um but um
you know
you look back 35 years later you know 33
years later i guess it is and you look
at the situation and you know
had any one of many factors been
differently maybe we would have chose
differently but i had grown up my whole
life
attending pro-life rallies with my mom
and you know like i loved kids so so my
every every person knows and like every
other photo that i take is with a baby
right so
so
for me you know it just had to do with
the fact that
he didn't need to pay for you know
what
what most people would call him my own
my mistake like it wasn't that and that
he's a human and like who are we to
decide
when you know when life begins and so to
me that was
that was it and you know was it hard is
the hardest thing i've ever done in my
entire life and
um you know and every single day
for his whole life i just prayed that
someday i'd find him and
and you know and so
yeah those dreams come true
can you uh
tell the background so that everybody
else yeah yes i was thinking i should
have dead so can you tell me how that
happened i i think not too many details
not too many details
yeah well i mean oh tell them how you
met tell them yeah tell them the story
yeah how did you mean i don't think any
of us really know this because i know
those
at least that well they got introduced
via um the other siblings yeah it was
you can explain it yeah
okay
my
brother was engaged to
her sister
yeah yeah nobody knows this so yeah i
let them tell the story
and so i was really cool back then
i had a i had a perm which you
you have hair
there's no pictures that perm still it's
just
imaginary perm yeah and an elvis shirt
on so what more cool could you do than
that
yeah and so actually we we used to back
then the day we used to go boating a lot
i mean like a lot my brother had a
decent boat we used to go boating on
lake grapevine and um in dallas
and so her sister since she obviously
was engaged to my brother she ended up
staying the summer with her
and um and so she came out voting with
us and the first time i met her was
actually when i was voting on
one of those trips we probably went four
or five days a week we bought it an
awful lot back then that's why
they have more
knee board not knee boarding weights
anybody two with two skis and one ski
so and so you can continue on the rest
of the way after that when you saw me
yeah what made you guys like each other
you know for me like this one this one's
super easy okay he looked like he needed
a little bit of polishing yeah he was
like a gem that needed a little
polishing adam he's probably a little
better off than i am
he uh he had on uh white tube socks
black slides um elvis king t-shirt that
had the collar missing and these shorts
that were way too short with rainbows on
the sides and a perm he needed a haircut
[Laughter]
but i can tell you for sure it
one of the first trips i think it was
the first trip out in the
lake he had his nephew christian
on his
shoulders and he had his nephew danny
standing on skis and he was skiing with
both of these little kids um
on his skis and i just was like that's
like what i'm attracted to is like
people that you know love kids because i
love kids and so to me that was you know
we could cut the hair
so rude and what made you like mom
you know what it's kind of like
everything else you kind of just fall
into things
in some ways like just like you said
with greg you're just like like right
now i kind of i'm not sure it was the
right decision because all these phone
calls i get how to fix things
so i'm not sure on that one anymore
but it's kind of amazing to watch
somebody who
honestly don't think like adam can fix
things austin can fix things chas can
fix things that they never had the
exposure to it
and now greg has getting like he's
getting exposure by owning his own house
doing his own things so it's kind of fun
to actually just help him get through
the
stuff so what made you like mom when you
met her
i don't know i mean
hannah the one bad thing in my life is
my memory is like the worst thing i have
i mean i think she was hot back then
[Laughter]
mom or dad you might need to clarify by
not saying hop back then just say hot
and gentle
afterwards
but if you look back back then i have
some a cute picture of on lake michigan
like i took of her on a rock all by
herself actually it's more rocks but the
picture might look like she's in the
slack by herself and it was just i don't
know
i mean we just we both people from the
country that really
worked hard and enjoyed life was it was
it easier because your families like
knew each other
no that was harder that actually was
just the opposite that actually caused
friction oh really oh god yeah oh yeah
for sure i mean because i indirectly i
wasn't really blamed for but you know i
was blamed for my brother
and her sister breaking up so
i don't think i was very blamed it's
just that it was a sore point oh really
yeah
so
when did you find out you were pregnant
mom
um
like
i don't i don't understand the question
like like after that summer where you
still
oh yeah it was my summer my freshman
year of college sorry i didn't
understand what the
context was yeah so i went back to
college and that's when i found out i
was pregnant so
so did your hearts drop like what was
that like
it's like hard to i mean it was i guess
it just was another problem to solve i
don't know like we're problem solvers
and so you know i mean every solution to
it went through my head i don't you know
i would have had an abort there was a
point when i was going to have an
abortion i thought about it i did think
about it because it's easy right it's
easy button and nobody knows and it just
goes away and and then actually i still
have the card hanging in my office from
the
lady at um
i guess it was a crisis pregnancy center
that i went to
and
you know i don't know she just
she knew better she saw through the 17
year old or 18 year old at the time
person that was there probably making
the you know wait what did she do
well she just kept asking me why and you
know what what were my reasons and i
didn't have good reasons right
and and to be super clear it was a very
short-lived moment in in my pregnancy
but think about if
i had had easy access to just go
you know make a bad decision
what that would have you know what that
would have looked like it would have
been super sad
so
and um
so when you guys gave him up for
adoption what was that like because i
can't even imagine like carrying a child
and like seeing him and giving him away
yeah i mean
it was just really hard like that
there's i know i keep saying that over
and over again but that's like what it
was and so we did a semi-open adoption
so i chose or we chose i guess his
parents
um and
like just funny thing funny but not
funny like
i knew that if he was going to be
adopted he needed to be in like a kind
of a strict house because i thought that
you know he needed to be around people
that were going to keep him like on the
straight and narrow because
we're kind of you know
outliers i guess in many ways so
um and then when we met his parents it
was like they were exactly that so you
know and then
we went through that whole process
through catholic charities and then
um
when he was born he went to
foster care for three weeks or no sorry
he was born june 13th and the adoption
was final july 5th so whatever that time
was but he stayed with a family in
la crosse wisconsin and
yeah and what do you say to people that
will say well the foster system is so
bad like you can't put kids in the
foster system like because
it seems like adoption um was it hard to
access a good family like why why do so
many kids end up in like bad families in
the foster system
i guess i don't know enough about the
foster system as a whole to answer that
so i don't i don't know that i can tell
you from my personal experience and from
my experience with people that i know i
know a lot of really amazing people that
are a part of foster systems and have
been successful in it you know people
will paint broad brushstrokes for
whatever topic they want to
to you know create facts on right so um
the woman that fostered greg was a
marvelous person actually i went and saw
her a couple years ago
um just absolutely a wonderful human
being
so you know i just don't think it's
you know it can be used said broadly
again yeah i'm not i don't know enough
either i don't know about the system so
i couldn't comment
but i think there's just opportunities
if people are open
you know and they listen to to their
callings um
you know there's lots of opportunities
both for kids and for families so just
for the record though
it was her decision mm-hmm so not it
wasn't ours or hers and just because i
would have thought differently i
probably went the other route
so really oh yeah for sure back then i
was lost
so
so
but that's what
time does for you
but it was her decision for sure
so
uh yeah i that's like one when i learned
because um a lot of people don't know
this but i didn't know i had um a
brother until i was 22. and i don't did
anyone have any idea
eva told me actually
no
oh no because you weren't there girl
wasn't there girl wasn't there for oh
she wasn't on that trip okay so let's
back up because we didn't actually tell
the story of how we found out about
craig so sorry we went to my cousin
rebecca's wedding and we all had a
really good time and went out to the
bars after and had a good time we all
ended up back at the hotel went to bed
and woke up and we have a flight at like
1 p.m 2 p.m and we're all waking up
hungover tired and go get breakfast or
come back
everyone else is fine maybe maybe me and
austin um and so then we come back and
we're we're sitting in our hotel room
packing up and dad goes come on guys you
got to pack up quicker quicker come on
he's freaking us out and getting us
rushing and we're all like we have like
an hour and a half before we have to
leave and he goes we have something to
talk to you about it's really important
get your stuff let's go gets us all
packed up into the room we all get
packed in and we're all done and then uh
we're sitting in the room and mom starts
telling us the story and she starts off
and we you have another brother and
we're all joking ha ha ha i think hannah
goes oh you adopted another one yeah
well they said they said his name is
greg and i was like what kind of name is
greg
we're just roasting them and oh and then
mom goes uh i had him when we were when
i was a teenager and and then hannah
goes uh you you couldn't escape teenage
pregnancy got us there
and um we're all just roasting her and
just going off dad hasn't said anything
but he's laughing so hard he started
crying and then he just simply goes guys
and everybody shuts up
i remember specifically mom goes i
raised a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
she did say that word for worship
well because you kept interrupting and
it was a really hard moment and no
nobody thought it was real
i thought you and dad were just pulling
a big big prank on us it was such an odd
timing i was like we're on a vacation
right now we have to drive back home
after this like it was just such odd
time and then dad got serious and i was
like oh shoot
is
i've not seen my father cry many times
in my life but that was one and
yeah that was what really got us all to
understand that yeah this is real and to
make it even worse my
dad goes you're about to meet him in a
week
well that was the that was the urgency
to the whole thing yeah that i had met
him and uh yeah and we were gonna he
wanted to be connected to you guys
because you know that was a big question
to him and i had communicated with him
for i don't know maybe about a year
before that because i wanted him to be
really sure that he wanted to be a part
of
this whole story this mess because you
know he grew up in a very simple life
and very different from a very good life
but a very different life than ours and
you know what i told them is this is a
one-way turnstile you can't go back out
so you know the minute that they all
know when you have kids of varying ages
like what's the most
what's the right time there isn't you
know there's it's hard to know well it's
really hard because emilia was still see
i didn't want to do it because i want to
make sure me that was old past 18
before he did it
but whatever again it was her choice
[Laughter]
no i that was like the
i've like never had more respect like
like that was i was blown away because i
just can't even imagine being 17 and
being able to do that like
you must have been wise beyond your
years because i i can't even imagine
giving up a kid for adoption well see we
could have kept going that way but the
odds are high first off we were both not
in the wrong directions in life
and so if we did take them
then i i'd like most the chance of thus
you being allowed to probably pretty low
so
yeah it actually
probably brought that
in time let us give us time to get
things going and then have kids as a
whole so
and he and i would also say that
i wasn't wise beyond my years it made me
wise beyond my ears wow and so
you know hard things like
hard things create strong people right
and so i you know again like what the
questions that you've asked throughout
the conversation today
so much of it is because people don't
know how to survive hard things and so
you know i came out of the gates as an
adult doing something really hard and so
i think you know that changed me
dramatically for sure yeah so after i
went down see
my perfection wore off on her and so now
she's perfect
it just works
so um after that you guys gave him up
for adoption
and then later um you guys started a
business
well we kind of all did it all together
i
mean
that was like the next phase of your
life i would say starting we were
already working on that when yeah well
she was going to school though and then
i was
working already and so then things kind
of merged together
over a little bit of time because she
wanted her to get to school finish
school just like all your kids want you
to finish college i don't care you don't
like it you finish it you finish what
you start
[Music]
you can still go back
that is where you start dad
that's the point see i learned from my
mistakes
a couple of them
two
and then
yeah two two i can think of a good thing
my memory is short
and that's the point that you actually
learned from what you did in the past or
just wrong in the past
so don't get
don't do either one of those two
mistakes
so what there's such a a lot of people
on my channel um didn't grow up with two
parent homes and that's why they're
really enamored when they hear me like
talk about have like growing up in our
family
what advice do you have for young men
that want to because my audience is
mostly men so what advice do you have
for young men that are feeling lost and
like want to be successful in life
well i i guess it's kind of like it's
like even i'd say to you the same thing
is that not saying you're lost but
i i don't have um
like do what your passion is
and if you do your passion no matter
what it is it will lead you to
success
and if nothing else it would lead you to
happiness on your own or happiness with
money is still going to lead you down a
road
that will make you satisfied
and so like when you told me you want to
do a youtube career tic tac thing i
thought you were nuts but i mean i'm not
i'm serious i i'm we're so anti-social
media that just because i just don't
deal with it but it was your passion
so because it's your passion a 100
percent back you man i think it's great
i think you're chasing what you want to
chase it's the best thing in the world
chase your dream
and i feel like i did i did the same
thing i changed my dream and i was i was
good at it and same thing you'd be good
at it so whatever you do if you do it
with passion and you put the time and
effort into it you'll be good and that's
what most people don't realize is that
you can't just give up i mean you've
been doing this for several years and
now you're starting to go because you've
followed your passion it takes time it
takes effort and when you do that i
don't care what it is i don't care if
it's walking dogs
whatever you love do it do it well and
figure out a way after that to make it
so you can do it for a living
so yeah hannah adding on to that i think
that
so many people allow fear to drive them
and that's probably one of the things
that our family does best is just you
know it doesn't like just drown out the
noise and you know when people are lost
out there they're lost because they're
listening to the noise and if they just
drown it out
um you know it's it's i had a revelation
about something that really
kind of has a dark start but it's a good
thought is that i was thinking about i
saw a drunk driver one day and i thought
it was amazing like all the people that
that person missed they missed a
pedestrian a bicyclist a couple of their
cars and i was like wait
the odds of them hitting somebody are
probably pretty low like in general
but
we all focus on the the most horrid part
of it which is horrible i'm not taking
away from that but i'm saying that that
we all focus on all of the things that
can go wrong instead of just focusing on
what can go right
and most things every single day go
right but people don't think about that
they spend all their energy thinking
about what could go wrong
and you know and and i think we're in
this world that people are afraid
they're just afraid of everything just
stop being afraid
and just go live
yeah that's something that i think is
unique to our family too because
everyone has like such a go-getter
attitude
and um
that's that's i think the best piece of
advice
dad you've ever given me because
otherwise i'd probably still be working
in sales like that would have been the
safe route but i'm like a million like
you guys see it a million times happier
doing this rather than that
soul-crushing copyright
but wait what again are you doing oh
sorry
yeah i still don't get it i'm not gonna
lie this is what i do except i
argue i'm just like i usually am arguing
with people
are we arguing about who's the best
sibling which is clearly me
me
[Laughter]
that's jazz
yeah
and then what so then another question
from the chat is what advice do you have
from someone that
wants a big family and wants to raise a
lot of kids
i love this one can i oh sure
um
again it's like
just do it and most people they have
kids and they stop living and i watch i
watch person after mom after mom after
mom and they just stop they stop living
they stop going and you know when you
know adam was three weeks old i think
when we took him on a nine country trip
in europe and you know he got his
passport on the first like on the way
home from the hospital and we just did
it and and people are like well this
might happen that it might but it might
not and so you know having a lot of kids
doesn't cost
like the same amount of money
exponentially and i remember when you
guys were little and we would spend you
know we get our credit card bill at the
end of every month and it was a certain
amount of money and then as we had more
kids it didn't really change because you
stopped going out to eat you start you
know handed clothes down you can afford
to do a lot more
and
the value and just the joy that was in
your four walls you didn't have to go
pay for it outside those four walls and
so yeah is it hard there's a lot of hard
days but you know when i'm 51 years old
51 i always say i'm 52.
who rounds up i don't know
um you know i'm 51 years old some of the
best gifts my parents ever gave me
wasn't you know wasn't an education or
anything else it was my siblings and so
you know i hope that
when you look at your life and you're 51
years old i hope you feel the same way
that it wasn't the trips or the car or
the you know whatever it was you know
your the people you're surrounded by
so what do you think dad
i'm sorry um tips for raising a lot of
kid and having a big family oh i don't
know don't don't don't take too much out
of it
don't i get inside i don't think
everything is a crisis dying the walls
are falling and just sit down and hey
that's how you notice guys most times i
don't like sometimes i react don't get
me wrong but for the most part i just
like okay
what's going on now who's yelling at who
who's it now
so i mean you guys and i spend a lot of
my life you guys may not think that by
being like a peacemaker i do my best
maybe too much because eva pushes it a
little too far
what do i do
that's the point you answer my question
writing uh what do you do okay
but the point is you just gotta not
not everything is not a crisis life is
just
it's just a sit back figure it out
get through it go to the next point and
so just enjoy it try to enjoy it i mean
don't be in like a hot studio in the
middle of sorry
we're all melting yeah yeah
london doesn't have to have ac i don't
know what you guys are doing out here
yeah it's the hottest day of the year
and like how long
like
forever but
being organized helped too
if you have your health
there's nothing else i'm watching my my
siblings like to start dropping
because the health you must have your
health and so if you have that if you
don't lose a limb lose a foot little leg
you you can always get through it you
can't start again you can always do
something it's health that's the problem
i mean it just says i mean i'm watching
it so seriously now i watch my sister my
brother my other sister i mean i think
it's four or five now that just it's
just it's sad
and there's and that's the one thing you
must maintain and if you do that
everything else doesn't matter you go
live in a beach then somewhere if you
have to but
if you don't have that and you paint a
lot the time and then life sucks i just
watch it no that's the one thing i
always say about you when i'm like
telling people stories i'm like my dad
can stay calm in anything and like
whenever i'm freaking out about
something you're so good at like
bringing me down to earth i mean like
it's not that big of a deal calm down
you're not dying
your house is on fire don't worry about
it
even like when i was here i lost
everything i lost like everything on a
train like my id my wallet like
literally everything and i'm like crying
and he's it and you were just like
you're fine just order new ones
what are you gonna do like dad i'm
locked out of my apartment you're just
yeah i get a lot
call locksmith adam lost his laptop the
other day yesterday got stolen and then
a day it sucks but it is what it is i
blame dad for that i wouldn't have taken
it out of my bag but yeah it was my
fault i forgot it on top of the car yeah
actually actually be honest chas
actually recommended you taking out of
the car bag but that's okay but the
point is that that's the point it's not
that important plus it's an old piece of
[ __ ]
it's a horrible laptop so it's it's it's
going to help you more because you get a
new one crack screen weight a lot it's
horrible didn't really run that well
yeah so for that reason
why they steal it because they're stupid
okay
it was sitting on top
it gets worse this is the worst part of
the whole this the funniest part is yeah
he first lost his wallet
okay so first is no no passport oh i
don't know this is
[Laughter]
and so finally we actually
give up and then adam downloads this app
called i have i have a tile in my wallet
yeah it's a towel which is unbelievable
like i think no way that's not gonna
work you're full no wait hell so we're
walking around this car with this tile i
kept saying stronger stronger weaker
weaker stronger stronger
we couldn't find it like it was like the
nuttiest thing in the world
and guess what it has the driver's door
is this real long pocket and i'll be
damned the wall was all the way back in
that pocket i was like shocked that damn
the thing worked
and i checked there i just want to make
this clear i stuck my hand back there
and on the wall yeah the wallet was
lodged up somehow i'd gotten stuck up so
when i reached my hand back there i
reached and felt nothing so then i
assumed there was nothing in there
somehow i got lodged up in the into the
door and it just was there
and so then we spent like 20 minutes
searching for this wallet and then we we
finally find it so i just grab all my
stuff apparently not my laptop too but
and then
we start walking away we walk all the
way inside and we're about to go through
security and i go hey dad i think i
forgot my laptop
we go back and i searched strip search
both cars completely down no laptop and
so yeah it was gone yeah and we think we
left it on top of the car so whoever's
walking by is it it was like late at
night three groups of people like
there's very people who are taking it
yeah but whatever whatever it's gonna
help in the end just it's just kind of
funny how the whole thing works out well
it's like a mindset because you can see
the good in anything yeah because you
think a new laptop yeah
i think it's like just don't make
everything into a crisis like it just
doesn't need to be you know there's
gabrielle fell while hiking the other
day
adam was chasing me
he was chasing me and red car um was
trying to defeat blue car but blue car
still won
but she had stitches and you know and
but first of all she finished the hike
you know we didn't just turn back we
finished it you said i could though yeah
but but it was a mindset right it was
yeah it was it didn't whether she got
stitches or had a hole in her knee as
long as she was wanting to keep doing it
why wouldn't you keep going but i would
say if we knew the energy if we knew the
extent of the energy in an injury we
probably thought yeah we should take you
down carrying it
but we didn't and you know and then we
kept going we just went to the er we got
it stitched up and you know we went to
went to the next place so the whole
point is is it's just a mindset to just
keep going just keep going did you do
you guys feel like there's problems that
come with success
like there's problems walking across the
street
when it comes to like jealousy and that
sort of thing um i don't know i think
people are i think people are jealous of
happy people
that's more true
really i don't care if you're happy or
anything
yeah cause somebody's always somebody is
always there to knock you down it
doesn't matter and so you can't let it
bother you
i mean you just can't it's like okay you
did great well good good for you
the trouble you have is that it doesn't
matter it's not not about
success it's about anything in life
somebody will you can't like i guess
even with you you thought the comments
are probably bad you can't it
sometimes we give you some nasty
comments what life's about
and you got to say hey you know what
whatever just move on
i think when we started the business you
know when we were not yet successful all
of our clients were successful that's
why they were buying software and so i
think we had surrounded ourselves
accidentally probably by a lot of
successful people and a lot of happy
people and so
it helped us aspire to that um but just
in general i think that there's always
people that are
you know wanting to take you out so you
know if you just drown out the noise it
goes back to the exact same thing it's
like it doesn't matter what they think
that's right
you just gotta look back look at life
and say
it's for you to make the most of it out
of it how you feel and by doing that you
gotta again follow your passion don't
worry about whatever else thinks if you
worry about what i thought i mean if i
he asked my advice for you i'd given you
initially are you nuts
i never told you that but that's how
internally i just don't understand it
and that's but that's okay though but
you you do understand it and you
followed it and that's that's great
that's that's what you want to do and
that's what all your siblings want to do
whatever whatever it is
i mean i mean eva eva is like so much so
much talent that it's like so many
different things that she's just so so
good at and just follow the one you end
up loving just and that's th and that's
why i would gladly help you help her
help anybody
because even chaz okay
and that's the point because it's your
passion that has to take you in life
because you're not happy life sucks
you're not happy and don't have your
health life really sucks i've seen so
much of it in my own family so my my
brothers and sisters was like oh my god
and so that's what i'm saying those two
things you've got those two the money
doesn't really matter it's those two
that are
so
yeah hannah you had a i saw something i
that you put out there and you said you
were at a private banking event and
you're with all these wealthy people and
you were the youngest person there and
probably in
the world the eyes of the people in
there you were the most
wealthy person because you were you had
your youth on your side you had health
on your side and you were really happy
that was a fun event
no that's true because i was thinking
about all the money in the world can't
buy your health and it can't buy youth
no and so if you don't
um if you don't have your health
um
like i i think that's the saddest thing
to be honest and like you have and
that's why i think sometimes like in
this world we forget how lucky we are
just to like wake up every morning and
not be in pain right
i think i thought about it when i broke
my leg in 2014 like you know i couldn't
walk they told me i would never run
again without a limp and i'd never walk
i've never walk again without a limp and
i'd never run again and nine months
later i ran the chicago half marathon
and i just decided i was gonna do it and
i went about it like a job and i you
know the doctors told me to start
physical therapy in six months i was
running in six months and so i just yeah
we do it different in the davis
household
but that leads to her other points now
other points that she had a great
physical therapist
and that's the catch you got to have the
people surround the people around you
with good people
so if you do that then it makes your
life easier well and i took ownership of
my my health and that's the other thing
right now i think our medical care
system wants they want control of your
health and they want um you know and
they want you to just surrender it well
had i listened to them i can tell you
that everything they predicted would
have been true but i just that wasn't
for me and i wasn't going to do it that
way and so you know my point on that
whole process is i had a fantastic
physical therapist i went to my doctor
and i said if i was a professional
athlete how would you treat me
is this what you would do well then
after much heating and haunting they
finally said no this isn't what we would
do i said okay well my health is as
important to me as a as a professional
athlete is and so you know went through
the whole process but what was
remarkable is i finally got through all
of that and it was horrible i couldn't
run i mean i couldn't drive i couldn't
do anything but then like one year later
i saw a flashback come up on some social
media site and
it was like wow i have forgotten to wake
up every day and be grateful for just
walking
and so you know i think we just become
so
in grateful um
for what we have and our you know our
health is what we have
well um i just wanted to say
publicly thank you guys so much for all
you do
um because honestly like i'm so grateful
to you guys because i wouldn't have
built this show without you and you guys
were so supportive when i would cry all
the time
well you're welcome and small bills work
just fine
yeah i've mostly forgiven ellie for
pooping in the house yeah yeah and even
like um i don't know there was just in
the past couple of years there were
times where i really wasn't in the best
place and you guys like supported me so
much and like helped me out of that
um and so thank you so much for helping
me build the show my original sponsors
you guys bought my first sound board
[Laughter]
um so i'd like to go around i know we're
hot and we want to get moving on the
road so why don't we just go around and
if anyone has any last like thoughts
they want to say or anything
um
i just wanted to start by saying thank
you so i love you guys you guys are my
favorite people in the world thank you
yeah you too
oh he actually admitted you are the
favorite hannah
i go back to my original question after
that i have no favorites
it's a competition he makes us compete
for it
thank weekly i can be bribed
it's like survivor
[Laughter]
no i don't have anything
chance isn't always this quiet by the
way
well it depends what year treasury going
for like is it 2020 2018
there's different types of chassis
eva do you have anything you want to say
got to keep the health dad how's your
coca-cola doing
right afterwards
after we're done melting
i'm all wrapped up thanks for having us
on hannah yeah thanks for coming guys
appreciate you all
yeah thanks mom and dad for bringing us
here
it's always a pleasure thank you and
please get ac in britain hey at least
she saved us from the hood look guys if
you want to join our memberships it's
going to help me pay for rent next year
and then maybe i could get ac
[Laughter]
if you guys have any final thoughts
anything you want to say
yeah just we're proud of you and uh you
know i mean i think every parent's proud
of their kids obviously but um
hannah you've been singing and
entertaining since you were born so
there's no surprise that this is uh this
is where you ended up and and what
you're doing so you're quite
entertaining so thank you
just follow your passion
i'm proud of you
well guys this is the the family that
you guys have heard so much about um the
people
the people no i think you i've probably
told stories about all of you so no she
said he said some of them like not
everything oh oh
yeah minus
greg austin yeah there's a couple gone
so
this is the most you're gonna get in
europe maybe we'll do a chicago show one
day
um okay guys um thank you so much for
watching um let me know in the comments
what we should talk about next week this
was a pop-up show so i won't be i'll be
back on the 26th that'll be my first
show back
um that's going to be with sarah garvey
that's going to be the gray area let me
know in the comments what you guys want
us to talk about then
sign up for our memberships and it has
been telling me to plug my facebook page
so um just dot or not not facebook
instagram just dot pearly things that's
my instagram we have a new facebook page
a new twitch go like that subscribe to
the channel and we'll talk to you next
time